but the moral of the story is that you
have to give people what they want
in order to give them what they need
[Music]
what's going on everyone in this short
video i want to tell you a story about
how you can position your marketing way
that gets
a lot more people to respond to it
independent of whether you may like it
or not
and so when i was starting out right
i struggled to get people to buy what i
knew would help them
right so when i started in fitness i
wanted to say hey there's a sustainable
way
uh to look the way you want to look you
just need to learn how to count your
macros and
and uh and and do resistance training
and if you do that you look the way you
want to look
but for whatever reason my marketing
that talked about that because i knew it
was true
didn't get people to respond right and i
didn't get any new customers even though
i knew
i was saying the truth right and
later on in my career uh before i
learned this lesson
i was doing marketing for a dentist uh
and i was
and i was running ads and and we had
landing pages that we had built and it
was working
and he called me up furious and he was
like this looks horrible this is
terrible for my brand
i would never sign up for something like
this and i was like well it's a good
thing that you're not your customers
you already have nice teeth right and so
the story that that rant that drove this
home for me
was a story that's become famous in our
community called the ham and the garlic
and so the way the story goes is there's
a little kid
and he was incredibly uh excited
to please his dad right and his dad one
day
decides to give him a dog and says
listen son you gotta take good care of
this dog and if you don't take care of
the dog then it means you're not
responsible
all right so you gotta take good care of
it if you're if we're gonna buy it he
says okay
so he gives him the dog and so one day
the dad goes to work you know a couple
weeks later
and the kid sees the dog he's playing
with him and you notice he's got ticks
all over him
and he's like oh my god he's super
distraught he's like what am i going to
do what am i going to do and so he runs
over
uh into the other room whose grandmother
who's looking after him while his dad's
at work and he says grandma
like what what do i do the dog's got
ticks all over him
and the grandma says ah mijo you just
have to
give the dog some garlic all right so go
feed him some garlic and then the ticks
uh you know will go away so the kid goes
and he tries to feed the dog garlic and
the you know the dogs
move in his head because he smells like
garlic he doesn't eat it right
and so uh he goes back to the
grandmother says grandma i i i try the
garlic it didn't work what do i do
and she says meow did you just try and
give him the garlic
straight up and he's like yeah he's just
ah
you know you have to wrap it in ham wrap
it in ham first then feed it to the dog
so he's like okay so he wraps it in half
and goes to the dog the dog eats it and
then
a couple you know an hour later the
ticks start crawling up the wall
uh because it's the dog starts you know
sweating alcoholic whatever right
and the kid feels saved because the dog
is taken care of and the dad still is
proud of him etc
but the moral of the story is that you
have to give people what they want
in order to give them what they need and
so many times people are not at the
perspective from which to
they don't have their perspective they
don't have the context to understand
what you're saying because you already
in the know
and so you have to go back in time to
before you knew what you knew
what you know now and meet people where
they're at and then walk them across the
bridge to where you need them to go
and so when we started marketing fitness
we would market you know short
short duration challenges detoxes things
like that
because we knew that people who were in
that state of mind
what they want is a quick fix right and
so what we would have to do is we'd
bring people in we'd give them what they
want to get them to respond
and then once we earn their trust we
said hey i know you had a little you
know we had some success in this first
you know a few weeks but you're not here
just for a few weeks because you don't
want to gain it back right
of course not right you really want this
to be a long-term thing because if you
lose it and gain it back what's the
point
they're like yeah it's like and at this
point we said this is the garlic what
you need to do is you need to learn how
to count your calories
you got to learn how to eat macros you
gotta learn how to train for real all
right
and so when we had that we now had the
context to have the truthful
conversation with them and deliver the
garlic
right but it took the ham to get them in
the door
and so right now you may have something
that you're trying to market in your
business and you're trying to get your
customers in the door
and you're marketing from a position of
already knowing the answer
and that's the issue and you may shake
your fist at these other these other
marketers your competitors they're like
and you're like man they're they're
marketing short duration things that
they're marketing these
whatevers right but they're probably
marketing it because it's working for
them
and so i'd encourage you to shift your
perspective from saying this is the
truth
to this is their truth right now and i
need to meet them where they're i have
to go back across the bridge to where i
used to be
talk to them in that language relate to
them understand their problems
and their fears and then with my once
i've convinced them to trust me enough
then deliver the the garlic to them so
you have to
give them what they want in order to
give them what they need and this is in
essence
what a lot of great marketing is
especially if you have any type of
business that has any sort of
transformation that you're delivering
anything that the other person has to
take some steps towards you in order to
be successful
and so that story's always stuck with me
because it applies to any type of
coaching or mentor mentee relationship
or really anything that you're you're
marketing to the public where you need
them to
break a belief in order to consume your
service or or get the result that you
need them to have
right or that they really need for
themselves and so many times you can't
begin with the end you can begin with
the end in mind
you do not begin with the end you have
to start where they're at
and then tape them along the journey the
same one you did so that they can get to
where they want to go
which is where you know is going to be
the best place for them so anyways i
hope this was valuable for you
if you like that i'm sure there's
buttons and things that you can click
and learn more and all that stuff
but anyways keep being amazing have an
awesome day and i'll catch you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you